[Music]
big controversy for the romney campaign
are you following this today
a secretly recorded tape of a fundraiser
has emerged
yeah this is what happened during a
private reception with wealthy donors
mitt romney
said nearly half of americans pay no
income tax
yeah
yeah then he said but enough about me
yeah he moved on yeah and another it's
true
another thing
another thing mitt romney said is that
if he had had mexican parents he'd have
a better shot at winning
that's what he's that's what he says in
the tape yeah
but unfortunately romney was tragically
held back by being born into the home of
rich white people
there's no getting around that you know
stuff
good news for the royal family a judge
has ordered a french magazine to turn
over all 200 topless photos of kate
middleton yeah
yeah the judge says he wants the photos
because he's having trouble finding them
online he just wants to take a peek
and what's with the
you know
than the joke i enjoyed your reaction to
the news story
we wanted those photos for ourselves
more royal
boobage no one calls it royal boobage i
do oh okay
the space shuttle is coming to la did
you know that space shuttle is coming to
la it's going to be towed through
downtown los angeles at two miles per
hour
in other words it'll be traveling at the
same speed as every other vehicle in l.a
it's true
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my commute every day
then a turtle goes by
carnival cruise line has announced a
brand new all-you-can-drink cruise
there you go yeah
yeah
yeah carnival said the unlimited alcohol
crews is a great way to inaugurate their
brand new ship the ss what could
possibly go wrong
it's interesting a prominent historian
is now claiming that jesus was married
yeah
yeah
because just like any other married guy
who goes missing for three days he comes
back with a crazy excuse
get this
okay
i died and i went to heaven i'm not
getting back
baby
i like my jesus is like ralph cramden
baby
i'm back
cigar
i'm jesus see
lindsey lohan sent out a tweet
complaining that amanda bynes has been
getting off too easy for her driving
violations
yeah
lowen sent the tweet from behind the
wheel just before crashing through a
pinkberry
it crashed
yogurt uh
a shortstop for the toronto blue jays is
in trouble for painting a homophobic
slur under his eyes
yeah but don't worry after the game it
washed off very easily in the group
shower
we uh
and then i got to mention this
scientists have discovered that there is
such a thing as a breast orgasm
a breast orgasm yeah
so sorry ladies that's one more orgasm
you're gonna have to fake
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
andy stop me from acting this out
i uh you were doing the hapless safe
cracker yeah that's what that was
that's my technique
and those are the noises i make during
sex um
[Applause]
[Laughter]